[Musique]
à travers le regard de nos collègues
dans différentes régions on vous propose
maintenant un retour sur une saison qui
n'a pas été de tout repos comme si on
n'avait pas assez de la pandémie
la météo a aussi fait des siennes ce qui
a entraîné toutes sortes de conséquences
[Musique]
encore une fois cette année le printemps
s'est enflammé des dizaines de milliers
d'hectares de forêt boréale sont partis
en fumée
pour la société de protection des forêts
contre le feu
la sopfeu le mois de juin a été le plus
occupé des dix dernières années
incendies de tourbières à rivière-ouelle
est toujours actif
fait rare le feu a aussi sévi beaucoup
plus au sud une tourbière et près de 400
hectares de forêt dans la région de
kamouraska ont été la proie des flammes
faut comprendre qu'un incendie
tourbières brûlent on timbre lancement
moureu profondément et va faire beaucoup
de fumée
j'avais du bourg broc pro boucherie
pendant restant de ma vie
les épisodes de canicule ont même eu
raison de la faune aquatique comme ici
dans le lac saint-augustin près de
québec
sedran à la première pour tous est si
intense si monstrueux robert bouchard
côtoie le lac saint-augustin depuis 1956
le livret a donc constaté un nombre
anormalement élevé de poissons morts
depuis samedi
et l'odeur qui vient avec dans le lac
saint-augustin un plan d'eau qui n'est
pas très profond tout comme dans ce
secteur de la rivière magog la chaleur
intense à accélérer la croissance des
algues et causé un manque fatale
d'oxygène pour les poissons les fraises
arrive ici au compte gouttes et
l'agriculture a évidemment subi les
conséquences de cet été chaud et sec
chez les producteurs de fraises
même si la demande était au rendez vous
l'offre n'a pas toujours suivi dans les
champs la crainte d'une pénurie se fait
sentir
résultat d'une météo bien particulière
cette année en coupe le prêter à
décoller ça a été très chaud très
rapidement ce qui a fait que les tout
les plans frei se sont mis à vouloir
produire des fruits pour les fruits
mûris donc on a pu on n'a pas le même
nombre de fruits le même calibre
une saison une saison moyenne on
accumule d'enfants depuis plusieurs
semaines afin de plus beau dans une
sécheresse presque jamais vu au québec
en fait c'est tout l'est du pays qui a
manqué doux au mois de mai et juin les
provinces de l'ontario jusqu'à la
nouvelle écosse ont reçu cinq ans
parfois 75 % moins de précipitations que
la normale
la situation a été particulièrement
critique ici au nouveau-brunswick
la firme terre partagée enregistré une
50e journée consécutive sans grandes
pluies et ce avant le premier jour de
l'été le fait que c'est au mois de mai
puis juin c'est vraiment le moment que
ce qu'on fait l'implantation des légumes
c'est une période cruciale ce qu'on a
besoin d'eau à quelques kilomètres les
pâturages de ce petit troupeau de brebis
sont desséchées au printemps on n'a pas
eu les grandes semaines depuis
d'habitude y avons dit que pendant deux
trois semaines a noté de la neige à des
canicules
parmi ceux qui garderont un très mauvais
souvenir de cette saison il y a
d'ailleurs les producteurs qui dépend du
foin pour nourrir leurs bêtes fait pas
vu autant de chaleur d'une période de
six jours d'affilée qu'il faisait en
train de pau et 36° mot j'avais jamais
vu son pierre turcotte appréhendent des
pertes importantes de fourrage cette
année en raison de la dernière canicule
chaque été les agriculteurs fauche
l'arche en deux à trois fois mais c'est
la première coupe au printemps qui est
la plus importante
elle compte pour 50% du volume total
cette année cette première coupe a été
catastrophique
au québec c'est le bas saint laurent qui
a été le plus durement touché tellement
que certains producteurs sont confrontés
à des choix difficiles on gardait les
chanter ça va être beau on s'attendait
d'avoir 45 bal
finalement un coup pressé on dirait
qu'ils font qu on a fait
denis pelletier a connu plusieurs
sécheresse mais cette année il doit même
aller chercher de l'eau pour abreuver
ses vaches ses dents mongin devant les
zones monde c'est normal
le catch par cet été aux juges de toute
l'europe cette maladie
la rareté du fourrage a fait monter le
prix en flèche par rapport à l'an
dernier le foin se vend au moins deux
fois plus cher cette année pour certains
producteurs cette saison difficile est
un militant de trop résultat il songe à
abandonner l'agriculture et à faire en
qu'en cas qui arrive en année comme
cette année avec le foin la route et du
joint survient c'est la goutte qui fait
déborder le vase pour certains
assistants et si l'a45 six producteurs
par semaine qui pense ici un an soit
avant les vaches de boucherie soit avant
les vaches laitières reçoivent en ne
roulant de machinerie que les vaches ont
déjà sorti la grandeur du québec
heureusement la pluie des dernières
semaines a permis à certains producteurs
de sauver leur dernière coupe de foin
à l'autre bout du pays c'est une toute
autre histoire qui s'est joué cet été
des précipitations plus élevé que la
normale ont fait mal entre autres aux
producteurs de cerises de la vallée de
l'okanagan et comme ailleurs au pays
les travailleurs ont manqué à l'appel
chaque année au moins 1500 québécois
traverse le pays et prennent part aux
récoltes en colombie britannique
cet été à peine la moitié a fait le
voyage est ici aussi la pandémie à
empêcher l'arrivée de milliers de
travailleurs étrangers
le bilan s'était tu peux paraître sombre
mais il ya au moins un élément positif à
retenir avec la coved 19
on a pris conscience de l'importance de
soutenir notre agriculture
sur le terrain cela s'est traduit entre
autres par des inscriptions record au
panier de légumes dans les marchés
publics
malgré des craintes initiales les
clients étaient au rendez-vous et pour
plusieurs entreprises agrotouristiques
c'est un été qui dépasse les attentes
[Musique]